بالنسبة إلى Ansel and Louella Fernandez ، فإن كسر
الخبز يعني أكثر من مجرد تناول الطعام ، إنه
يتعلق بجمع الناس معًا ، إنه ما
يقولون إنهم يحبونه في الإمارات العربية المتحدة ،
أود أن أقول إنها واحدة من أفضل البيئات
لتنشئة أطفال هاجر الزوجان
من الهند إلى دبي لمدة خمسة وعشرين عامًا
في الماضي ،
كانا كاثوليكيين متدينين
وعضوين نشطين في بعض كنيسة ماري الكاثوليكية
في الهند على الرغم من أن عدد السكان ضخم ،
فإن عدد السكان الكاثوليك داخل
الرعية صغير جدًا هنا لديك
عشرات الآلاف من الأشخاص في
أبرشيتنا وجنسيات مختلفة
وثقافات مختلفة  تتكامل جميع أنظمة القيم المختلفة
معًا وهذه بحد ذاتها
تجربة ضخمة ، وفي الجهة المقابلة من
الشارع يوجد مسجد صورة تلتقط
علامات الانسجام والتسامح ، إنه أمر
رائع حقًا في بعض الأيام عندما تعلم
أن الجو هادئ بعض الشيء أثناء القداس
وتسمع النداء  صلاة
نذهب فقط موجودة بسلام إنها
بيئة جميلة بيئة من
التعايش الذي يتجاوز
مكان العبادة هذا إلى بي  cnics في الحديقة مع
الأصدقاء والعائلات حيث
تجلس الثقافات والأديان المختلفة معًا وتناول الطعام
معًا وحتى تصلي معًا إذا
عدت إلى كتبنا المقدسة التي تعرفها
وتشير إلى ذلك سواء كان الكتاب المقدس
أو القرآن أو التوراة أو أي
كتاب ديني آخر  يتحدث عن
السلام ، نحن نمارس نفس الشيء في واحدة
من أكثر دول العالم تنوعًا ثقافيًا
يعيش الناس من مختلف الأديان بسلام ويجتمعون معًا
لكسر الخبز أو في هذه الحالة بيرياني
بيكي أندرسون سي إن إن دبي